welcome to the council on a European
summit day the 27 heads of state and
government meet regularly here in
Brussels today they have very serious
matters to discuss the disaster in Japan
the crisis in Libya and the euro are
going to discuss the situation in Japan
the situation of the nuclear plant in
Fukushima has showed me as a German
Chancellor that we cannot continue to
act as before this is an important
European Council I think it's important
that the countries of Europe show
political will show ambition and show
unity the changes in a number of Arab
countries are of a historic dimension we
must make sure that we're all on the
same page to define a clear line so our
action can be in concert with that of
the international community
as a whole sends a very strong and
convincing message to the international
markets that it is supporting a stable
euro and is supporting all eurozone
countries the 27 EU leaders are convened
by the permanent president of the
European Council Herman Van Rompuy Lucas
a European they're a group the European
Council is comprised of the heads of
state and government of the 27 EU Member
States I chair meetings of the European
Council of which there are at least four
that each year and in practice six or
seven seas who set the course say done
European Council gives the European
Union its main impetus by providing the
broad lines and priorities for new
policies all European citizens are
directly affected by what's discussed
around this table did you see it's here
that at the start of the meeting the
heads of state and government greet each
other but they're not the only ones who
use this room other meetings of
ministers and meetings of the council
are also held here such as the councils
and ministers of Agriculture transport
of the environment and foreign affairs
and each time you have the 27
delegations plus the presidency and the
Commission in attendance the council is
the main decision-making body although
it does increasingly share this role
with the European Parliament what's
specific to the council is that here the
Member States cooperate and negotiate on
a daily basis
this takes place at all levels at the
highest level with the European Council
at the ministerial level with the
Council of Ministers at the level of
ambassadors and permanent
representatives committee Co repair and
at the base level that is in the working
groups comprising national civil
servants
The ministers examine the Commission's
legislative proposals and share the
decisions with the European Parliament
in a large number of areas for all
legislative work the minister's
deliberating public and their debates
can be followed live online I think it's
right proper that our emphasis should be
on renewable technologies and energy
efficiency technologies particularly the
minister's representing the Member
States are committed by the decisions
that they take together today we have
agendas of the same we have to fix today
the 27 ministers of Economic Affairs
have taken an important decision to
stimulate innovation in Europe they've
given the green light to a simplified
European patent framework this will
considerably alleviate administrative
burdens on inventors is convinced that
enhance cooperation will be beneficial
for 500 million Europeans and all the
businesses in European respective
nations once a month
the foreign ministers meet at the
council under the presidency of High
Representative Catherine Ashton the
critical thing at the moment was the
decision that was taken under the
resolution 1973 to do everything that we
can to try and support the people on the
ground the people in Libya the High
Representative is also in charge of the
union's external aid Europe can launch
missions to manage crises in troubled
regions at the moment these European
ships are fighting piracy off the coast
of Somalia and European soldiers are
training Somali troops to help restore
order in their country
Europe citizens are at the heart of the
council's concerns for the ministers of
justice and Home Affairs that means
helping citizens to better enjoy one of
the great advantages of the European
Union freedom of movement as a recent
popular movie reminds us today thanks to
Europe there's no longer any need to say
nothing to declare
but somewhat repelled we be a suit
company it reminds me of when we were
young
when we crossed the border there was a
customs post and you had to declare any
Goods show your passport and when we
were with our parents there was even
some tension and we went to France or
the Netherlands or Luxembourg it was
kind of an adventure we really had the
impression that we were leaving our
country today where in Europe there are
no more borders you just crossed the
border without realizing it
psychologically speaking it's a
completely different world on a person
from seven countries which had decided
to abolish border controls we now have
25 this is an enormous extension of the
space of freedom in Europe return to the
European Council in March 2011 a big
decision has just been taken the pact
for the euro zone we adopted the euro
plus pact it will provide a new quality
of economic coordination we put in place
the economic government of Europe so I
welcome the steps the eurozone countries
are committing to take today we now have
the pact with the euro in addition to
the 17 euro member states we have six
states in support I think that's very
encouraging economy a dinged-up we hindi
I think we have no other choice but to
focus on the economy if we want to be
taken seriously in the world we need to
be strong economically if you want to
protect our social model we need a
strong economy in order to finance its
yielding therefore in reality our task
is simple greater economic strength
we can also defend our values in the
world more effectively to punitive